So today my topic is Epcoid Tumor Plus GDB for Relapsed Refractory Diffused Large B-Cell Lymphoma.
These are my financial disclosures.
So patients who have relapsed or primary refractory disease, particularly large B-cell lymphoma,
they receive CAR-T-cell therapy or autologous stem cell transplantation as a curative modality,
depending on the timing of the relapse.
However, patients who have large cell lymphoma, and particularly those with rapidly progressing
and symptomatic disease, often require bridging treatment while awaiting CAR-T-cell therapy.
In general, the median time from vein to vein timing is approximately 8 to 10 weeks.
So those are the patients in need of further treatment.
So the effective salvage or bridging chemotherapy, which offers high response rates, controls
the disease, is highly is warranted to improve outcomes of these patients.
So Epcoid Tumor, as the audience is very well aware, is a CD3, CD20 targeting bispecific
antibody.
And it is approved for relapsed large B-cell lymphoma after two prior lines of therapies.
There are emerging data showing high level of synergy between Bispecific and
chemotherapy.
So we propose the Phase II IIT, evaluating safety and efficacy of Epcoid Tumor and GDP,
which is gemcitabine, dexamethasone, and cisplatinum among relapsed refractory large B-cell lymphoma
eligible for CAR-T-cell therapy or stem cell transplant.
These are the key eligibility criteria patients have to have.
If they have relapsed CD20-positive large B-cell lymphoma, they should have received
at least one prior line of systemic therapy for large B-cell lymphoma, and they should
be eligible for stem cell transplant or CAR-T-cell therapy per physician discretion.
Key exclusion criterias were receipt of any CD3, CD20 Bispecific or any of the
component of GDP chemotherapy.
So this is a study chemo.
This was a finite duration, three cycles of treatment.
Each cycle consists of three weeks.
Epcoid Tumor was given in the standard step-up doses, 0.16 during week 1, 0.8 week 2, and
48 milligrams week 3 onwards, and each cycle consisted of three weeks.
GDP was also given in the standard fashion, two weeks on, one week off.
This was strictly an outpatient regimen.
No inpatient hospitalization following first full dose of Epcoid Tumor for CRS monitoring
was mandatory.
The key objectives were.
Complete response rates per Lugano classifications, and there were other secondary objectives
including overall response rate, duration of response, progression-free and overall
survival, safety and tolerability, and most importantly, feasibility of stem cell mobilization
or CAR-T-cell therapy.
This trial was designed for Simon-Tustin design, and this data reflects the first stage of
preliminary efficacy, and most importantly, the decision to move forward to Simon's
second stage of the study.
Total 14 patients were enrolled during Simon's first stage design.
Majority of the patients had advanced large B-cell lymphoma.
Double and triple-A lymphoma, double-X-presso lymphoma represented approximately one-third
of the entire population.
40% of patients had primary refractory disease, and close to 55-57% of patients had germinal
center as a cell of oresine, and prior lines of therapies were won, and, sorry, medium-prior
lines of prior therapies were two in the majority of the patients.
So, as you can see, the primary objectives were complete response rates, and they were
64%, and the study met the primary endpoint.
All patients received protocol-defined three cycles of efcoetamab and GDP.
All patients underwent successful stem cell mobilization or peripheral blood T-lymphocyte
collections.
Out of 14 patients when the data were analyzed, seven patients already received stem cell mobilization.
stem cell transplant, and three patients received CD19-directed CAR-T cell therapy.
The follow-up is extremely short at six months, but at median duration of response was not reached.
Median PFS was not reached, but at six-month PFS was 74%. The safety profile was most important
to us. I just wanted to make sure that the addition of APCO to GDP does not increase the
safety profile, and safety profile was highly consistent with what we observed with the salvage
chemotherapy, including cytopenias and fatigue and increased risk of infection. The CRS summary
was quite favorable. Incidence of CRS was 50%. The time of onset of CRS from cycle one day one
was 16 days, which is just roughly a day after the first full dose. Time to resolution of CRS
was within a day. Number of patients who require hospitalization for CRS were just one patient,
so it shows us that this is an outpatient-based regimen and
can safely be delivered, and majority of the patients had milder CRS and two patients required
tocilizumab for CRS management. So, in conclusion, APCO retumab and GDP regimen demonstrated early
signal of efficacy in relapsed refractory large B-cell lymphoma. This regimen is feasible to
administer in the outpatient setting as a bridge or salvage regimen prior to CAR-T cell therapy or
stem cell transplant without adversely impacting stem cell transplant. So, this is an outpatient-based
regimen. The study matches its primary endpoint and continues to enroll with the final accrual of 32
patients. As of a month ago, the study has enrolled 28 patients, so we are a little less than four
patients or so to finish this trial. With that, I would like to conclude. Thank you so much.